last time we
talked um you've you've talked about
this intuition that
we humans might be quite unique
in our galactic neighborhood perhaps our
galaxy
perhaps the entirety of the observable
universe we might be the only
intelligence civilization here which is
um
and you argue pretty well for that
thought
um so i have a few little questions
around this
one the scientific question
in which way would you be
if you were wrong in that intuition
in which way do you think you would be
surprised like
why were you wrong if we find out that
you ended up being wrong
like in which dimensions so like is it
because we can't
see them is it because the nature of
their
intelligence or the nature of their life
is
totally different than we can possibly
imagine is it uh
because the i mean something about the
great filters
and surviving them or maybe uh
because we're being protected from
signals so all those explanations for
um for why we haven't
heard a big loud like red
light that says yeah we're here yeah
so there are actually two separate
things there that i could be wrong about
two separate claims that i made right
not them
one one of them is i made the claim i
think
most civilizations
when you're going from simple bacteria
like things to space
space colonizing civilizations they
spend
only a very very tiny fraction of their
other
of their life being where we are uh
that i could be wrong about the other
one i could be wrong about is
this quite different statement that i
think that actually i'm guessing
that we are the only civilization in our
observable universe
from which light has reached us so far
that that's actually
gotten far enough to invent telescopes
so let's talk about maybe both of them
in turn because they really are
different the first one
if if we look at the n equals one
the data point we have on this planet
right so we spent
um four and a half billion years fussing
around on this planet with life right
we got and most of it was pretty lame
stuff from an intelligence perspective
you know it's bacteria and then
the dinosaur is spent then things
greatly accelerated
right then the dinosaurs spent over 100
million years stomping around here
without even inventing smartphones
and um and then very recently
you know it's only we've only spent 400
years going from newton
to us right yeah in terms of technology
and
we've look what we've done even you know
when i was a little kid there was no
internet even
so it's i think it's pretty likely for
in this
case of this planet right that we're
either gonna
really get our act together and
start spreading life into space the
century and doing all sorts of great
things or
you're gonna gonna wipe out um it's a
little hard
if i i could be wrong in the sense that
maybe what happened on this
earth is very atypical and for some
reason what's more common on other
planets is that
they spend an enormously long time
futzing around with the ham radio and
things but they just never really
take it to the next level for reasons i
don't haven't understood
i'm humble and open to that but i would
bet
at least ten to one that our situation
is more typical
because the whole thing with moore's law
and accelerating technology it's pretty
obvious why it's happening
everything that grows exponentially we
call it an explosion whether it's a
population explosion or a nuclear
explosion it's always caused by the same
thing it's that
the next step trigger is a step after
that so i
we tomorrow's technology today's
technology enables tomorrow's technology
and that enables
the next level and
as i think because the technology is
always better of course the steps can
come faster and faster
on the other question that i might be
wrong about that's the much more
controversial one i think
um but before we close out on this thing
about if
the first one if it's true that most
civilizations spend only a very short
amount of their total time in the stage
say between
inventing um telescopes or
mastering electricity and leaving there
and doing space travel
if that's actually generally true but
then that should apply also elsewhere
out there so we we should be very very
we should
be very very surprised if we find some
random civilization and we happen to
catch them exactly in that very very
short stage
it's much more likely that we find this
planet full of bacteria
yes or that we find some civilization
that's already post-biological and has
done some really cool
galactic construction projects in their
in their galaxy would we be able to
recognize them do you think is
is it possible that we just can't i mean
this post
biological world could it be just
existing in some other dimension it
could it
could be just all a virtual reality game
for them or something i don't know that
that it changes completely we won't be
able to detect
we have to be honestly very humble about
this yeah i think that i
think i said earlier the number one
principle being a scientist is you have
to be humble and
willing to acknowledge that everything
we think guess might be totally wrong
of course you can imagine some
civilization where they all decide to
become buddhists and very inward-looking
and just move into their little virtual
reality and not disturb the
flora and fauna around them and we might
not notice them
but this is a numbers game right if you
have millions of civilizations out there
or billions of them
all it takes is one with a more
ambitious mentality
right that decides hey we are going to
go out and
settle a bunch of other solar systems
and maybe galaxies
and then it doesn't matter if they're a
bunch of quiet buddhists we're still
going to notice
that expansionist one right and it seems
like quite the stretch to assume
that you know we know even in our own
galaxy that there are
probably a billion or more planets that
are pretty earth-like
and many of them were formed over a
billion years before ours
so had a big head start so if you
actually assume also that life happens
kind of
automatically on an earth-like planet
i think it's it's pretty quite the
stretch to then go and say okay so we
are there billions of
another billion civilizations out there
that also have our level attack
and they all decided to become buddhists
and not a single one decided to go like
go hitler on the galaxy and say we need
to go on and colonize or
and or not and not a single one decided
for more benevolent reasons to go out
and get more resources
that that seems seems like a bit of a
stretch frankly and this leads into the
the second thing you challenged me to be
that i might be wrong about
how rare or common is life you know
so francis drake when he wrote down the
drake equation multiplied together a
huge number of factors
and said we don't know any of them so we
know even less about
what you get when you multiply together
the whole product yeah
since then a lot of those factors have
become much better known
one of his big uncertainties was how
common is it that a solar system even
has a planet right
well now we know it's very common
earth-like planets we know we have
better
dime a dozen many many of them even in
our galaxy
at the same time you know we have thanks
to i'm a big supporter of the sethi
project and its cousins
and i think we should keep doing this
and we've learned a lot we've
we've learned that so far all we have is
still
unconvincing hints nothing more right
and and there are certainly many
scenarios where it would be dead obvious
if there were 100 million other
human-like civilizations in our galaxy
it would not be that hard to notice
some of them with today's technology and
we haven't right so
so what we can what we can say is well
okay
uh we can rule out that there is a human
level civilization on the moon
and in fact the many nearby solar
systems where we
we cannot rule out of course that there
is something like earth
sitting in a galaxy five billion light
years away
um but we've ruled out a lot and that's
already kind of shocking
given that there are all these planets
there you know so like where are they
where are they all that's the that's the
classic fermi paradox
yeah and and um so my argument which
might very well be wrong
it's very simple really just goes like
this okay we have no clue about this
it could be the the the probability of
getting life on a random planet it could
be
ten to the minus one a priori or ten to
the minus five
ten ten to the minus twenty ten to minus
thirty ten to the minus
forty basically every order of magnitude
is about equally likely
when then do the math and ask how close
is our nearest neighbor
it's again equally likely that it's 10
to the 10 meters away 10 to 20 meters
away 10 to 30 meters away
we can we have some nerdy ways of
talking about this with bayesian
statistics and a uniform log prior but
that's irrelevant
this is the simple basic argument and
now comes the data so we can say okay
how many words there are all these
orders of magnitude 10 to the 26 meters
away
there's the edge of our observable
universe if it's farther than that light
hasn't even reached us yet
if it's uh less than 10 to the 16 meters
away well it's
within earth's ray it's no farther away
than the sun
we can definitely rule that out you know
and
so i think about it like this a priori
before we look to telescopes you know
it could be 10 10 meters 10 to 20 10 to
30 to the 40th and 50th
equally likely anywhere here yeah uh
and now we've ruled out like this chunk
yeah and most of it is outside and here
is the edge of our observable universe
yes yep so
i'm certainly not saying i don't think
there's any life elsewhere in space
if space is infinite then you're
basically 100 guaranteed that there is
but the probability that there is life
that that the nearest neighbor it
happens to be in this little region
between
where we would have seen it already yeah
and where we will never see it there's
actually
significantly less than one i think and
and
i think there's a moral lesson from this
which is really important
which is to be good stewards
of this planet and this shot we've had
you know it can be very dangerous to say
oh you know it's fine if we nuke our
planet or ruin the climate or
mess it up with an underlying ai because
i know there is this nice star trek
fleet out there they're going to swoop
in
and take over where we failed just like
it wasn't the big deal that the easter
island
losers wiped themselves out it's a
dangerous way of lulling yourself into
false sense of security
if it's actually the case that it might
be up to us
and only us the whole future of
intelligent life in our observable
universe
then i think it's both it really puts a
lot of responsibility on our shoulders
inspiring
it's a little bit terrifying but it's
also inspiring but it's empowering i
think most of all
because because the biggest problem
today is i see this even when i teach
right so many people feel that it
doesn't matter what
they do or we do we feel disempowered oh
it makes no difference
this is about as far from that as you
can come up when we realize that what we
do
on our little spinning ball here in our
lifetime you know
could make the difference for the entire
future of life in our universe you know
how empowering is that
you